play one more game with against wesley
and then maybe we'll play hendrick
carlson
so knight f3 c5
oh i uh
actually also played the accelerated
dragon
although it was when i was 14.
takes bishop uh e3
win d2 fabiano has many good games
in this line
but
yeah i can't remember exactly whether he
played f4 or f3
or whether i should play f4 or f3
f4 has got to be the critical move here
but he can play rook c8
and attack my pawns so
it should be slightly better for white
but there's a problem that white can get
too comfortable with this position
yeah so here f4 knight v5
look at fate doesn't look right
um i think i can go f4
and then bishop after
yeah 10 year old these days is the new
14
queen v7
uh
i don't exactly know what to do i think
i can
push oh i just blundered 8x bishop d4
okay 5 e5
let's play knight b5 and then e5
winning the exchange ciao
ciao knight c7
take
um if he gets his bishop on d4 it's
gonna become a bit messy
so
takes he's got a lot of pawns on the
king side
five pounds that's a lot of puns
but i have a past pawn
i have two pass pawns
which are well supported
[Laughter]
spawn
if you get the win take
you have one knife move
grab a bun
yeah we win
okay how do you win this yes here
i should play rogate
regardless check
yeah so finally
managed to beat 10 year old wesley two
games in a row